there is innovation in cultivated meat  or what people might call lab grown meat  there are two dutch companies which are  quite large and one of them just this  week announced that they have been able  to lab grow the first pork sausage that  could be a new model for  farmers and for the dutch food industry  to at the very least maintain the level  of meat production that we have now and  potentially grow it do you know much  about the lab-grown meat when they grow  meat do they grow a muscle tissue is  that what the end product is the way  that has been described to me is they  take animal cells and understood in a  certain growth medium it is grown and at  the end of the process you have a piece  of meat which looks and tastes and  spells exactly like a real piece of meat  would